okay mentor I just two more two more
hang in and these are gonna go
relatively quickly but I would like you
to see tonight at least these six the
mentor can be any person any age as long
as they pass on skills and wisdom to the
hero they can there can be more than one
mentor in a story like Star Wars there
are several mentors going on there the
mentor often dies but not always the
mentor gives a hero a life-saving gift
and that is almost always that's what
happens whether it's knowledge or it's
an actual gift or if it's you know
teaching the hero about the power of the
force that is a life-saving gift that
obi-wan passes on they can be also
dishonest in morale or a reprobate
that has nothing to do with what we're
going to be seeing now here but like for
instance what a league of their own
you know the Tom Hanks part the drunken
guy who gets the job of being their
coach a reprobate and turns into quite a
meaningful and powerful mentor character
can be dishonest or immoral or a
reprobate and can be negative this one
gets overlooked sometimes can be
negative and be teaching or trying to
teach the hero the wrong way to live in
the firm you might remember that Tom
Cruise film the Gene Hackman character I
forget the character's name but he's
assigned you know then he's the new the
new be the Tom Cruise character he is a
son he's the partner of the firm who was
assigned to teach him the glories of the
ways of working in a firm that their
major client is the Mafia and he shows
him in a very sad way because he was at
one time a very
man and how this how working for this
firm had but he doesn't even know this
is what he was showing him but how it
has sucked the soul out of the guy he's
crushed by what he has done with his
life okay some successful mentors I'm
going to show you the matrix I got a bit
on the matrix here Morpheus is you know
the classic father figure of all time
Penny Lane also interesting as I mean
she is a young woman groupie in almost
famous and she is teaching the hero
what is 16 year old I think sport a
music writer
how do you know groupie world you know
how to be a groupie and following and
following a band and basically she's a
negative mentor teaching him how hollow
this life really is
Mathilde and Leon the professional how
many have seen that one yeah runs
late-night you know they play it all the
time it's really a terrific movie if you
get a chance to see it I mean you don't
have to go out of your way but if you
get a chance to see it see it because in
this case the mentor is a 12 year old
girl and because her mother and father
are killed by the bad crazed bad guy and
she takes up with and follows and and
and seeks for protection Leon who is
himself a hitman for protection but what
she ends up doing is giving Leon a
reason to live teaching him about life
yes it was one of her first one of her
very first films and it's I think a very
powerful film anyway Simon and as good
as it gets and Chaz Reinhold in wedding
crashers if anybody remembers that one
again he's a negative he's a negative
mentor there and even in The Wizard of
Oz okay okay I will assume most of you
have seen the major
Trinity this in in jirobo this is the
end of hero gol sequence v and Trinity
has taken neo up in this strange
building to meet Morpheus for the first
time and he's been built up as it's
quite something and it's important to
meet him and it's an honor to meet him
so she says and he asked her I think is
there anything I should know and she
says be honest he knows more than you
can imagine
so knock knock and they go in over by
the window waiting is Morpheus and the
first thing he says is at last neo says
it's an honor to meet you and Morpheus
says no the honor is all mine
this mentor is already giving his gift
right upfront his gift to the hero and
it is the gift of knowing that he is
special and that he is chosen by their
mythology by the rebel mythology and all
he has to do is come to believe it
himself
and that's his arc his growth are I
imagine you're feeling a bit like Alice
tumbling down the rabbit hole all the
images all those images are coming into
play here even Alice Through the Looking
Glass that's going to get used here in a
minute - you're here because you oh yes
listen you're here because you know
something you can't put your finger on
it but you've always known that
something was wrong and the reason I'm
particularly pointing out this passage
is that is the state the emotional state
of almost all heroes in the first act
they are living in their own world their
own in their life yesterday the world
they've always lived in and it's just
day-to-day and you know okay it's there
and they do it but they know that
something is wrong it hasn't been even
maybe he hasn't even been articulated
yet
but something is wrong with society and
what they don't know is they are the one
who is going to set it right
Morpheus says you were born into a
prison you cannot taste or smell or
touch a prison for your mind can you
imagine when this first came out and was
speaking to young people teens and young
people all over the world how they're
just sitting there nodding and saying
yes yes that's me that's how I feel
the identification here was complete
with an entire generation you cannot be
told what the matrix is you must see it
for yourself all I'm offering is the
truth and then the classic moment when
Morpheus offered the two pills picked
blue or pick red big blue you wake up in
your bed then you go on about your lives
and you forgot this all together pick
the red and there's no turning back so
of course the hero picks the red and
that is the inciting incident when he
chooses and swallows the red pill that
is what begins this story and no other
he is defined by that act and there's no
going back that has already been stated
through him so that is the end of here
we go sequence five and it pushes us
into hero goal sequence six and cypher
he meets you meet some some of the crew
cypher says buckle your seat belt
Dorothy because Kansas is going bye-bye
and things start to get weird and change
and the mirror starts to flow and he
touches it if you'll recall and then the
mirrors latches on to his finger and
starts pouring up his arm and there's no
stopping it and it's about to drown him
not looking good for ya but then this
this takes him boom he wakes up in a you
know in a
tank-like thing and covered by membrane
and tubes and he fights his way out
right it's like being born it's a
metaphor it's being reborn into the real
world he fights he gets up and he takes
a look outside of his own pod to see
millions and millions of other pods just
like it you've been living in a dream
world neo this is the world as it is
today
watch this what do we call that look
bingo stunning surprise one for neo he
wakes up and he sees the real world for
the first time eyes open wide mouth open
drippy with birthing goo yeah
it takes place 33 minutes in which is
just about perfect and welcome to act 2
neo he is thrown into this new world in
which his entire adventure and story
will take place welcome to the desert of
the real
we've done it Trinity we found him again
a reiteration of the fact that the the
mentor is utterly convinced that this is
the chosen one who is worthy of all the
instruction that now must be given okay
mentor can be any person of any age yes
can be more than one mentor in a story
in this case actually there's only one
mentor the mentor often dies but not
always in this case he almost dies he's
captured and he's tortured but he does
not die and I think there's a very good
storytelling reason for that I won't go
into it now but somebody remind me later
and we may have a discussion about why
the mentor is actually allowed to live
here in this story gives whoops did lose
gives a hero a life-saving gift yes
belief that he is extraordinarily
special can be dishonest not relevant
here can be negative not relevant here